what's happening people we are going to
start kingdom season two today i think
there was a big misunderstanding
uh and that falls on us for improperly
communicating so i'm gonna be very
upfront with you guys we're doing this
right now but there's not gonna be a
reaction to kingdom next week the reason
why we said we said in the finale for
season one we just got so much coming up
this month yes there's christmas and new
year's we want to celebrate some time
with our family have some down time but
then we also got like probably a lot of
spider-man the week spider-man comes out
and then we got witcher season two so
we're trying to finish switch for season
one there's also a book of boba fett
after that and then cobra kai starts so
it's just a lot of mapping out and we
cover a bunch of shows at patreon as
well that's why we were saying like
we're gonna need just a tiny bit of a
break wanted to start this up here so
that you guys know it was not the plan
to wait like a long time to stop we were
just trying to recalibrate and i figured
what better way to get the word out than
just by starting it and letting you guys
know that next week there won't be one
but the plan is to pick it up again uh
regularly after that and for those who
are concerned like no you can't wait two
weeks to shoot it our viewing experience
is not the same as the editing thumbing
uploading experience for you guys so
oftentimes we'll shoot in a very
specific order so we won't be lost it's
just the uploads are going to be a tad
weird but the plan is the week after
next make it be regular shuffle again we
good
yeah let us know if we're good let us
know if we communicated that fine so you
guys don't think we're stopping the show
but hit that like button full length
watch logs under patreon and hey thanks
to the boys that prep for writing this
down let's watch this after that
cliffhanger
[Music]
so he had this plan for years
he knew exactly what it would do
who did you test this on
god how ominous
let's try it on all of them
wow
what a lovely murder do you think he
killed the emperor just to use the
resurrection plan that is now an
excellent question i i could absolutely
see them doing something like that
god
cool
wow
jeez
crushed
oh man they pulled an all-nighter i know
they're just about to celebrate
yeah can we get these things back on
fire please
just burn the whole
freaking place man burn all that brush
hawkeye
oh oh my god in the water
get in the water oh my god no
no
oh how
nice this guy can't die
protect him yeah
he's the new young shin
wow epic shots
jump for whoa
oh
it's smart
good thing you knew exactly where to
jump yeah
wow
what a season two opener i guess i
wanted this to be the opener yeah
wow
oh my god the big one
[Music]
we can't no
[Applause]
man knows what it needs to do
[Applause]
you get multiple heads right there yeah
holy [ __ ]
damn jesus wow
what an opener
casually push him off
shoot his hand come on put it put him
out of his misery
[Music]
the precision of all filmmaking all that
opening sequence from choreography to
editing
uh staging the effects oh brilliantly
that's beautiful so brilliant
it's a marvel to behold man absolutely
that's what it best says it doesn't stop
oh my god
oh my god
let's go fast
break the gate for the love of god
there's enough of you that could
probably break that lock
[Applause]
i don't know if you guys are going for
the head yeah
and you get your heads in the game
help him
oh dude what are you doing
oh he bit though oh
damn it his only reason he's the best
fighter i know there's only one reason
you step up and be a hero
no you can lock it from yeah
[Applause]
die a warrior man
[Music]
oh man this is freaking the lady and the
guy inside the river
they're at the the origin site of the
plants yeah you guys now's not the time
to slow it down
they're just at the opposite end
[Laughter]
you
[Music]
[Laughter]
secrets are coming out
bring us a boy damn you
hey maybe
and you might just be dead
[Music]
[Laughter]
people are very nice
who is it close up on the hay for
something ominous to be returned to
later
maybe there's a hatch under there
oh wow he knew all about this disease
from three years ago
um and then i'll go beat myself just in
case
but also for the love of god please
don't let it be him
oh
man
oh i trust you dude i'm all about you
man all about you man i love you
you're like my favorite
[Music]
when they were barricaded he cared about
nothing but getting used to safety dude
absolutely
okay so one problem after another yeah
oh that's why they focus on the hay yeah
that's where it started probably
oh jesus christ man
i can't afford any [ __ ] accidents
huh
what if you take the resurrection plan
while you're alive
[Laughter]
like the opening scene
so they can all die yeah so walking to
death
[Laughter]
wow running the eyeball find the cure
that's the way you defeat them yeah
have them meet each other
everybody just donate a pint and we'll
splash them around
[Applause]
so fascinating both sides of this wall
they're both starving
[Music]
foreign
hell yeah
go
new world where the infected
and the living get to yeah
everyone has rights yeah
you can feed uh you know cho hawk jew to
the to the monsters and there you go now
that would have been a season one ender
i yeah
as much as i as it's got me really hyped
for season two i mean that would have
been insane that would have been the
perfect season one was right there
cause i'm pretty sure they shot this
back to back yeah
usually you can tell when there's a
difference in quality
theory usually you can tell when there's
a difference in like uh that guy's
haircut looks a little bit different
than something on there yeah things have
gotten a little more streamlined in the
production yeah but this looks way and i
can't imagine like let's do all let's
bring all those extras back to those
same shots and you know yeah so
it feels like it just would have been
the smart thing to shoot this back to
back and um
yeah watching this i'm like
this would have been the perfect season
one ender yeah
yeah you're charging off into what feels
like truly the next part of this story
i'm very fast and maybe they just wanted
to keep the episode counts the same i
don't know what the exact episode count
of season two is but yeah
let's talk about it well that was
fantastic the the battle
sequence in the first half of this i
love when they have those episodes like
that where like the last half or the
first half is just a big action sequence
it's just really tense and taught and i
think that like that's when this show
excels at just
awesome precision like the calculation
of how they handle
the the choreography and
the editing you're dealing with so like
you you guys
really
cannot stop taking it for granted
stop it it is so
difficult to
just
map that out and you got so much
different footage and it's gotta
mo and at the end of the day you gotta
be able to tell what's going on
while mainly eliciting the right type of
uh tight grip tense emotion that it's
supposed to generate within your soul
that is the hardest part about it is it
could just look like a chaotic mess so
you gotta calc you gotta like assemble
chaos
in a way that is readable
yeah there's an orchestra yes and you
have to build this rube goldberg machine
and not only do you have people on the
technical side capturing things in real
time but you got to make sure your horde
of zombies and your horde of survivors
are all in the right places moving these
cannons and all these different things
the stunt work yeah yeah it is a major
set of stage of choreography like as i
said choreographer you usually think of
like fight scenes or something which it
is um but i'm talking about like just
the amount of how many shots there were
and how many moving tracking shots there
were two and you just got to think of
the escalation as well
uh the stunt work around it with i was
just so phenomenal and uh
they they they have such a good grip on
on how to capture those sequences like
nothing more can be said that was that
was one of the best and
i can't imagine being in your guys's
shoes where for the fans who
watched it when it aired like season one
and then they had to wait like a year
for [ __ ] seasons
something pretty freaking amazing and
they delivered wholeheartedly like i
waited a long time now let's see what
they do here oh yeah it's just it was
hypnotic and tense like it's it's hard
to i think to mix those two together
because they did such a great job of
choosing all these different lenses and
things but always keeping the camera
moving whether it be through a zoom or
whether it be mounting it on top of a
canon going through a hole to the horde
or even if it's just a cut back to
somebody on the top of you know a wall
it's at least a little shaky like they
really sculpted all of the motion and
that in a visual sense communicates that
whole idea that this is non-stop you
can't take a break there's no breather
and there's
players on all angles yeah you know it's
like when you're doing a movie you get
so much time to prepare for something
like this and that's not easy to do on a
movie like think lord of the rings helms
deep battle for example right
and you have to
factor in like okay these characters are
here these characters here they're up
here they're down here they're by the
water you know yeah you gotta cut to all
this yeah you can have it flow and make
it all feel like it's happening just
over there or just over here and yeah
not lose everybody in the geography yeah
you have to really have the geography
mapped out as well and it's it's
deceptively hard to do that when you're
thinking about camera angles and shots
and reverse shots there are you know
rules to those things and then you also
on top of those rules have to make it
look engaging
and yeah this was like expert filmmaking
to the max to the point where that whole
openings that whole you know you get the
quiet opening sequence with the slight
origin you know that you know explaining
how we got here but yeah you get one of
the best
zom like action and also zombie action
set pieces i think i've ever seen oh
yeah because it had yeah everything you
would expect and want out of like a
visceral epic battle while also it
combined with just this really palpable
horror like it's it is truly pulse
pounding in both equal measure in action
and horror in that in those moments oh
yeah there's no disputing that at all
and and i mean the guy like the acting
too that comes out because so much of it
is just looks and intensity in the faces
of everybody and especially the guy who
plays the crown prince like he has so
much to do across this episode that's
all just in his face as he's processing
the entirety of the situations he's in
and well he wants to save the people he
would never want to leave or abandon
them at the same time he knows how
important it is that he stays alive
so it's just like he's in a constant
state of inner conflict
because it's like he would never we know
him as a character who would gladly give
his life to be here but he can't also
give his life yeah yeah so it's just
brilliantly acted and a lot of great
reveals there um like with the lord on
and the uh
cho hawk the looking at the the
background that they shared together
because they let on that he knew a
little something more yeah you know
especially when they first heard when
when you first cut to him in a few
episodes ago and he's like meditating or
something yeah and you see that oh he
he's aware of when they said like
they're coming back he didn't have a
reaction like wood
he obviously knew of this
and to learn you know the that they did
weaponize this infection prior and it
also too makes it like even earlier on
there's that whole thing about you know
uh
talk to you being like we gotta get to
lord on before the crown prince does
because if we can do that we might be
able to sway him to our side and i'm
especially getting that context here i
was like yeah i could see how you know
if he was the first one to get there he
could spin this situation
and so yeah they make that palpable too
just the kind of fragility of the
relationship and and yeah his whole role
in the thing his whole when he tells
that one guy off about like it's what we
needed to win the war oh we get it all
over it's funny for some reason even
though it's like a
historical fiction zombie show
the the comparisons that constantly run
through my mind is lord of the rings
specifically the hobbits religion
the part of the rings trilogy is the one
that constantly runs through my mind
when i watch this and game of thrones
didn't do that
uh no other show i've watched does that
but this one does i think because of the
practicality and the way the action is
staged too that's what reminds me of it
and then right down to
at the um
with the plot progressing of
you know how to say it sipo
uh so silby so b and what's the guy's
name oh crap uh uh
uh funny man funny coward the magistrate
coward
i just i've been calling him magistrate
guy this old guy that was calling that
uh joe hawk cho cho magistrate guy yeah
and nurse lady uh who would
when they're when they when they decide
to flee to cho hawk and joe
joe hawk jew cho yeah joe hawk jew then
they just decided to flee to him
and the way that progresses
makes you think of return of the king of
what happens with pippi yeah you're like
oh [ __ ] you're working for the enemy
yeah and that's the only way you stay
alive now
it's going to be it's extended eating
sequence in the next episode she's got
to sing to him now
yeah and you don't really know what his
plan is it's like
whoa would he be anti-eliminate the
disease when i'm like well how does it
behoove you to keep the disease alive
yeah
and they're so great at like he's great
at pulling that out of you where you're
like i feel like any prospect that of
yours is going to be nefarious but also
i guess i kind of want to find out
though like maybe there's more to like
his political you know aspirations are
so dastardly that i almost wonder if
there's maybe something more nuanced in
whatever this is about to become with
him yeah exploring
more of the infection with them mm-hmm
um yeah there's just some great
emotional scenes like what was the thing
with young shin and and the guy
is there a beat i'm missing or is that
something to be unveiled later i wasn't
sh i wasn't certain i couldn't tell if
we maybe lost something or if it was
just a human moment to maybe be
expounded on later because i do
appreciate there's definitely a history
with him yeah yeah because he
couldn't look at him while i was
happening he couldn't look at him and
kill him and he was like i'm sorry and
that he clearly stayed behind and had a
moment where usually i feel like young
shin would kind of just take care of the
job quickly
okay yeah that's fair i guess in the
moment i i took that as more of like a
you know he'd be leveling zombies all
day not batting an eye but when it comes
to this of like
you made the ultimate sacrifice so that
we could get the hell out of here i i
you know i almost don't want to look at
this because this actually breaks my
heart you know but i think your
interpretation is probably a lot more
likely uh and yeah if there was
something
i imagine it was subtle because you know
they also seem to have a certain level
of skill i mean we never see the other
guy use a gun it seems like as far as
the warriors go they are two of the most
quick-witted incompetent so i can see
maybe they had time together hunting
tigers or something
yes exactly there might there might have
been maybe it's to come later on
um and then yeah the the sequence the
scene with mu young and the crown prince
that broke my heart i think i i i feel
like it sucks because i'm like i don't
want to completely defend my honor in
case i'm wrong but we show logic
that we love him so he must hurt us by
the end
but when you watch especially dawned on
me when they were trying to get through
the the the barricade when it was locked
right when they broke through the first
thing he said
the first thing he's trying to do is
protect at all times he's trying to
protect him so why would he
try to sabotage him or or get him killed
or something like that you know yeah i
mean i feel like if the if their goal it
seems like the chose want the crown
prince dead and i don't feel like they
care as much at this point to be like
let's do protocol i feel like they would
just want to kill him on spot so yeah
you know i feel like muyong would have
easily had the opportunity to do that so
to me that's a mark yeah against like
i mean
when would he have had the opportunity
unless he's dropping little notes or
sending birds out
and uh yeah he's given so much and
risked so much and puts his all into it
way more than like a deceit seems like
it would merit because every single
minute he's risking life and limb you
know and then we got the prophesizing
with the queen
yeah
but i think that's a mislead that's got
to be a missile i mean i think it's
limited to the principle of the crown
prince will come back yeah
yeah and also too it's like
misinterpretation of the prophecy yeah
and and probably some some kind of just
comeuppance for that character of like
oh you think you know in in trying to
orchestrate this grand machination and
now turning to some kind of you know
offering ritual
you know that's going to backfire it's
not actually going to happen for you
it's probably not even real and you're
going to yeah probably cross blades with
the crown prince instead all right guys
well kingdom season 2 hell of an opener
for sure
leave your thoughts down below on what
you thought um or either i don't know
what to say
but we will
we'll probably shoot one next week we
won't go up for another a week we just
it there's only so much time in a day to
get things out episode two's gonna take
a few hours to put one of these together
so thank you guys so much for being here
and uh let's do a pic
deontay w tongue punch fart box my dude
if there's anybody who i would want to
be trapped with in a zombie apocalypse
it's not it's not you because you would
draw them right to us with your
flatulence and your constant tongue
punching you know smell awful yeah stuck
with that guy it's already gonna smell
bad with guts and you know viscera lying
everywhere nothing's worse than a fart
yeah and then to add a fart on top of
that it's like as much as i love shawna
the dead and that ending scene i'm like
i'd never want to smell what's that
smells like yeah so deontay
listen when the when the big one hits
you got to become an adult and uh you
know stop farting everywhere
but what if that is the key to defeating
the enemy what if his the fart box is so
strong that it reaches up their nostrils
and into their brain ultimately killing
them pierces their brain yeah and now i
can just imagine the opening credits of
this show but this fog is all brown
yeah yeah and that's all because of
deontay while they're leading them over
he's just farting into a box
yeah yeah yeah there's an early scene
where like a zombie approaches you think
it's going to eat deontay and then all
of a sudden you just hear a little fart
slip out and the zombies
totally repulsed runs away
and then you're the savior of mankind
through you know comedic cowardice
all right deontay i guess you're on our
side that's called character
[Music]